من اول ما بدا الفنان ياسر العظمه ينشر
محتوى برنامجه الجديد على قناه على
اليوتيوب واللي اسمه مع ياسر العظمه
الانتقادات ما بتتوقف وكل حلقه بتعمل
بلبله من كم يوم نزلت حلقه من البرنامج ثم
ياسر العظمه دراما يدموع العين دراما على
وزن سكابا يدعون دموع العين سكابا وفيها
فتح النار على الدراما السوريه وخبط في
مختلف كده الاعمال لكن النصيب الاكبر من
النقد والجهولي مسلسل باب الحاره الشهير
اللي يمكن ما في احد متابعه على الاقل سمع
فيه وفي ناس بتنتظره خلال الموسم من 12
سنه بيعرض خلال رمضان وتم الاعلان كمان عن
الجزء 13 هذا الموسم ياسر العظمه تكلم في
الفيديو عن مسلسل باب الحاره والقائمين
عليه بهذا الكلام
معظم مسلسلاتنا السوريه عم تكون مسلسلات
تنبه بان من يقف خلفها اما ان يكون جاهلا
او اميا او تاجرا او غبيا او مغرضا او
كلها المعاني سوا
باب الحاره يلي عم يحاولوا جهدهم يعملوا
منه امام المسلسلات السوريه بما يحمله من
تاريخ مزور وافتراء سافر على عقبه مهمه من
تاريخ سوريا والجن الجديد والمشاهد العربي
عن الظن انه هيك كانت اجواء بلادنا عقيد
وزعيم وابن عمي وابعده وخناجر وعنتريات
ونسوان مسحوقات وقصص بتلاع النفس
اكشن المسلسل الغير واقعي بس ما حدا لحدا
وكل ما ازداد اللوم ازدادت التناحه
والجراره وراح يستمر باب الحاره باجزاؤه
الى يوم القيامه شاء من شاء وابا من ابا
يلي عم يكتب المسلسل
[موسيقى]
شو هالتجني الممزوج والافتراء التاريخ باب
الحاره قصه متخيله فانتازيا وهميه ملا
اساس بتسيء للتاريخ السوري وبتشوف الحقائق
وبتعتم على اسماء كبيره
الكلام هذا اللي تكلم فيه ياسر العظمه عن
العمل ما مر مرور الكرام وعمل رده فعل عند
القائمين عليه رد الاول جاء من منتج العمل
محمد قبلنض اللي قال انه اي احد يجيب
سيرته او سيره باب الحاره هو شخص غيران
لانه مو مشارك في المسلسل وشخص بيبحث عن
التراند لكنه كمان ارجعوا قالوا انه بيحب
ياسر العظمه مو زعلان من هجوم على المسلسل
ورد على ياسر العظمه عبر برنامج اي تي
بالعربي والمؤلف رده كان اقصى وطالب
العظمه بالاعتذار
الاستاذ ياسر الفنان الكبير ولكن يعني
ينقصه الكثير من الموروث للشعب الشامي هو
هلا عم يساوي الترنجلا
للمنصه تبعه وعم يساوي ترينج كلهم مثل
المرايا لا دراما السوريه الدولار